[Music]
this morning we are dedicating an hour
of our show to a live special aimed at
taking the shame and the blame out of
discussions about mental illness the CDC
estimates one out of every six adults
will have depression at some point in
your life
some psychiatrist now recommend a
different approach to the treatment this
alternative uses magnetic pulses to
stimulate neurons in the brain Jamie
yuccas spoke to a woman who has tried
this treatment Jamie this approach
sounds a little daunting what's behind
it well Gail antidepressant medications
in psychotherapy are of course the
first-line treatments for major
depression these treatments however do
not always work for everyone in some
instances this treatment that you're
talking about called deep transcranial
magnetic stimulation might be used as an
alternative or in combination with
medication as a therapy depression is
the greatest thief ever it robs you of
your life your happiness your joy Marsha
Terry has lived with depression for most
of her life at her lowest point last
year she says she was unable to leave
her apartment for months and I thought
there's no hope I might as well just get
used to it I'll do the bare minimum of
what I have to do in life otherwise I am
just gonna sit in my chair do nothing
watch TV
Terry tried five different
antidepressants without success
her husband finally convinced her to
meet with a psychiatrist offering a
treatment called deep transcranial
magnetic stimulation or deep TMS
so it should feel a little bit more snug
when the person has depression a certain
area of their brain is under active dr.
Aaron Tendler is the chief medical
officer for brains way the company's
device uses magnetic pulses to create
electrical activity and stimulate the
areas in the brain that don't fire
normally in people with depression I
would say after the first week I was for
sure sleeping better so within the first
week of treatment you saw improvement
yes
patients undergo 20-minute treatments
five days a week for an average of six
weeks they can drive they can go to work
highly effective and low-risk and Terry
says these days she's feeling an
unfamiliar but welcome emotion joy it's
weird
I started noticing things around me more
one thing recently that happened at
about a week ago we were walking walking
home and I out of the blue popped into
my head and I said I love life I've
never said that in my life before you've
never said never said it before dr.
Steven Segal is head of psychiatry at
Keck School of Medicine at the
University of Southern California it
turns out there is nothing we have
that's perfect for everyone
he says the daily sessions can be
time-consuming and prohibitive and the
treatment can be extremely expensive if
not covered by insurance I think it's
important people know that TMS is only
one of the options available we have
talk therapy which is very effective we
have medications which are very
effective ready jump even after
receiving deep TMS patients may still
experience depressive episodes and need
further treatment works so well the
first time that if you go through
another bout of depression you'll go
back Oh 100% I will be on that phone so
fast I will never give up again
and I have so much hope the device is
FDA cleared but some experts say there
is not enough research on who this will
help and its long-term effectiveness
they say deep TMS is not for everyone
and that people experiencing depression
should work with their health care
provider to find the solution that's
best for them Tony
yeah not
everyone but hope is the word if this
helps some people that's a good thing
Jamie thank you very much just think if
you've tried five different treatments
and you feel that you're being robbed of
your joy and you think this works I see
why she says yeah I would do it again
it's another weapon against the wolf I
think you're in that position that's
like anything it takes you know all
right